these days it seems like everyone has
Netflix but as everyone fully utilizing
the service are they getting their
money's worth devouring the films and
shows they like in the most efficient
manner
here are some Netflix tricks hacks and
add-ons to enhance the streaming
experience while a lot of people watch
Netflix on a Smart TV countless more
binge watch shows in movies the
old-fashioned way on a laptop or desktop
computer Netflix is incident viewing
service was available on computers long
before Smart TVs came along and there
are still some basic functions of
watching that way that are still
embedded in the Netflix API like most
any other computer program Netflix
streaming code responds to hotkeys or
keyboard shortcuts meaning certain
functions are performed by pressing
specific keys no use of the mouse with
its pointing clicking and locating menus
necessary
they're also intuitive meaning the keys
do exactly what you expect hitting the
spacebar pauses and then resumes a video
striking app allows Netflix to take up
the devices entire screen escape shrinks
the video back down and tapping the left
and right arrows will rewind and
fast-forward respectively by 10 seconds
audio can be toggled to the end mutes
while the up and down arrows adjust the
volume accordingly even a casual scroll
through Netflix will reveal a few
examples of the services intricate
categorization system thanks to
complicated algorithms that factor in an
individual's viewing history it will
recommend exactly the kinds of content
it thinks a user will want to watch such
as thrillers featuring a strong female
lead or goofy showbiz movies Netflix has
thousands of these classifications and
they've all gotten assigned code number
for the sake of clean data storage these
codes are directly accessible when using
Netflix on a web browser simply type WWF
flexkom / prowl / onra into your
browser's navigation bar and after that
last / type in a three four or five
digit number at random and see what you
get or try out a few the categorizations
can be broken down into broad genre for
example documentaries can be found at 6
8 3 9 or at 871 1 categorizations can
also be incredibly specific sports
movies but only ones about martial arts
boxing and wrestling are at 6 6 9 5
there are plenty of circumstances in
which streaming things on Netflix isn't
advisable or attractive if only a person
could download a show or movie to their
device and then watch it whenever they
wanted
with no internet connection required
fortunately this is a very convenient
feature that Netflix quietly added to
its streaming plans way back in 2016 if
the content producer has opted in on
download ability there's a button right
below the movie or episodes description
simply click it wait a few minutes and
it's ready to go watching a movie before
Netflix was something of an ordeal every
night millions would descend on their
local Blockbuster or another retail
rental chain and make a beeline for the
new releases while only to find they
were all gone Netflix eliminated this
disappointment once and for all by
streaming a wide category of movies and
TV shows adding more every few days the
only problem with this is that Netflix
doesn't clearly delineate what's
actually new they've got a trending
section but otherwise it's going to take
a third-party client to figure out what
is actually truly new on Netflix that's
the whole point of flexible it's a
recomendation app that sorts through
Netflix and can be customized according
to genre user ratings language release
year and most attractively the date it
was added to the streaming service its
default setting lists the newest
additions at the top and it works
backwards as you scroll down the page
allow flexible to access your Netflix
account and you can play movies from the
service with a couple of clicks with an
interconnected world that loves the
binge entire series as soon as they hit
Netflix is hard to keep spoilers at bay
for someone who wants to stretch out the
view enum series avoiding leads to plot
twists or shocking character
developments is tough but not impossible
but sometimes Netflix will go and spoil
everything anyway it's not like the
service means - but those brief plot
descriptions displayed for every episode
that pop up on screen when a series is
selected can reveal a lot of details
enter super Netflix and add on Chrome
extension that makes for a truly spoiler
free experience it blurs plot
descriptions of individual episodes
while also obscuring the thumbnail
images accompanying those synopses like
virtually every other digital media
platform Netflix offers users a feature
by which they can make a list of movies
a TV series they can bookmark for future
viewing my list is necessary for Netflix
since it's easy to get overwhelmed with
choices that's why by clicking a few
buttons Netflix users can populate their
lists the only problem is that the
feature has one major flaw in that it
can't be rearranged unlike the old
toggleable Netflix dvd-by-mail queue
titles are listed by the order in which
they're at
however buried deep in Netflix's user
settings is a way to manually rearrange
the my list list it looks just like that
Netflix DVD queue except that it's got
all those things you can watch right now
or later as the case may be from one's
account page look for order in my list
and then toggle manual ordering watching
a movie on the couch with another person
is a true American pastime dating all
the way back to the 80s with the
explosion of the VCR spending the
evening watching a movie or a few
episodes of a show is pretty much the
same now only the content is delivered
via a high-speed Internet and because of
that technological breakthrough you no
longer have to be in the same room with
somebody to watch a movie together
thanks to a PC and Apple application
called cast friends at different
colleges of parents and kids separated
by a business trip or people urged to
stay home during a pandemic can share
entertainment watching TV with only one
person just isn't natural one part video
chat service one part screen sharing
software cast as an easily navigable
interface that allows both small groups
or collectives of more than 100 people
to all gather around their monitors and
watch the same video as if you're all
sitting on the same couch and of course
everyone can text chat about the video
in real time score dialogue and sound
effects are all crucial elements of the
cinematic experience but film and TV are
still visual medium nonetheless the
picture-perfect cinematography
breathtaking landscapes and physical
acting subtleties should still be
enjoyed by anyone and everyone even
those who lack sights entirely or are
otherwise impaired visually
luckily Netflix offers a free service
called audio descriptions according to
the streaming service it's an optional
narration that describes what is
happening on-screen the dulcet tones of
a neutral narrator dutifully describe
everything that's happening on-screen
such as physical movements costume
settings and scene transitions
the brunette lifeguard smiles
flirtatiously as she walked past filly
who pays no mind to her or any of the
ogling females in his wait isn't that
fun audio description is currently most
available on Netflix is deep cannon of
original productions and is sometimes
available on movies and TV shows
produced out of house it's a great way
to make movies more accessible to those
who can't see every detail that allows
us with full vision to enjoy a favorite
film or series in a whole new way
Netflix got its start in the United
States and as English is the most
commonly spoken tongue there most of the
services content is in that language
that includes blockbusters indie movies
licensed TV shows and original
productions that said Netflix also
offers an increasingly abundant array of
movies and TV shows from around the
world produced in the languages of their
countries of origin whether it's an
artsy French film or a reality show from
Japan
Netflix offers subtitles for its viewers
who speak and read only English they'll
appear in a standard bland font in an
easy to read color
however those might not work for
everybody and since Netflix is all about
near-infinite choice users can
personally modify their subtitles simply
go to settings then general then
accessibility and enable the closed
captions plus SDH after selecting style
viewers can change up the words font
color and size Netflix is obviously a
marvel of modern engineering and a wish
come true plenty of recorded
entertainment at once fingertips just a
click away on all for a monthly fee of
less than the cost of a pizza and yet
there is still fault to be found with
the surface there are certain mechanics
of watching Netflix features that take
one out of the immersive viewing
experience that are just plain annoying
some people don't like how if they stop
scrolling to read a synopsis a blaring
preview of that selection automatically
plays not everyone binge-watching a show
wants to see the title sequence play
every darn time and let's not forget how
the service periodically asks are you
still watching the developers of a
Chrome extension called never-ending
Netflix put a critical eye on the
streamer to offer up a workaround of all
those annoyances with a series of
checkboxes to toggle neverending Netflix
can allow users to always skip a title
sequence
autoplay the next episode turnoff
credits kill autoplay previews and
eliminate the still watching prompt
among other opt-in selections even the
most wonderful new technologies can have
it
side as Netflix's movie and TV streaming
platforms spread around a delighted
world in the 2010s it brought with that
a brand new social phenomenon called
netflix cheating let's say a couple
discovers a marvelous TV series on
Netflix every episode ends in a
cliffhanger necessitating the need to
watch far too many in one evening
because it's just so gripping at some
point bedtime arrives and a couple has
to turn off the TV that's when the
cheating occurs while the husband sleeps
for example his wife sneaks out of the
bedroom and watches a few more episodes
by herself without waiting for her
partner in television what do you want
to watch how about you black yeah okay
oh wait you're probably waiting to watch
that with Jeremy right
oh no it's totally fine Netflix cheating
really does speak to a betrayal of trust
not unlike other things spouses or
partners could do when the other person
isn't looking we're not advocating doing
this of course but there are ways to
cover one's tracks not only could a
Netflix user skip ahead a few episodes
by using an alternate profile on the
same Netflix accounts but it's also
possible to line edit the watch history
thereby destroying the evidence of show
cheating it's possible by heading to
one's my profile then clicking viewing
activity each recently watched item
appears and next to it a large X once
clicked that show disappears it can be
very hard to decide what to watch a
Netflix a person tired and weary at the
end of a long day of work spent making
hundreds of decisions may have a hard
time making just one more there's also
the possibility of spouses partners or
families not coming to agreement about a
Netflix option wouldn't it be nice if
somebody else like a well-meaning bot
just kind of knew what you'd like and
would put on that exact movie or TV show
for you waiting oh is the first one you
said bloodline yeah that's the idea
behind Netflix roulette a wild
recommendation engine it allows users to
enter in as little or as much criteria
as they want from what genre you want to
watch to whether a TV show or a movie is
preferred it even factors in how
critically beloved it is Netflix
roulette can take rotten tomatoes or
IMDB scores of a certain critical
benchmark into account after the program
has gathered all the pertinent info the
user clicks a big green spin button to
uncover a hidden gem in the streaming
service check out one of our newest
videos right here plus
more looper videos about your favorite
tips or coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]